ahora vamos a modificar nuestro arduino
nano para que funcione con nuestro robot
el nano que tenemos tiene varios pines
que sobresalen por debajo y estos pines
son geniales para colocarlos en una
tableta de prototipo pero no nos
permiten conectarlo bien a nuestro robot
en particular y es por eso que tenemos
estos conectores de pines hembra macho
que vamos a cortar en la cantidad justa
para que coincidan con nuestro arduino
los cortamos con nuestras piezas
alicates ya que cortamos esto vamos a
conectar los pines de nuestro arduino a
nuestro conector de pines hembra macho y
esto nos va a permitir conectar cables
fácilmente y que también nos facilitará
el modificar las cosas ya que de otra
manera tendríamos que soldar
directamente en nuestro arduino lo que
podría ser un problema si quisiéramos
cambiar algo así que queremos
asegurarnos de cortar la cantidad exacta
de pines en nuestro conector para
nuestra tableta arduino y hacemos que
coincidan los conecto
es macho hembra con el número de pines
que tenemos en nuestro arduino tomamos
estos pines y con cuidado los doblamos
90 grados usando nuestras pinzas es
importante doblarlos con cuidado y a 90
grados de manera que sobresalgan de lado
quizá tengan que doblar los varias veces
para que estén a 90 grados y que se
alineen correctamente ya que esto nos
facilitará conectarlo a nuestros
conectores de pines hembra macho que
tenemos en la mesa y ya que los tenemos
todos doblados y en el mismo ángulo
vemos que si los empujamos sobre la mesa
pues como que no están todos en el mismo
ángulo y tenemos que ajustarlos
perfectamente para que todos queden
horizontales y en el mismo plano que
nuestra tableta arduino así que vamos a
asegurarnos de hacer esto con cuidado
hasta que todos los pines estén
horizontales
de nuevo esto nos facilitará colocarlos
en nuestros conectores hembra macho que
tenemos aquí en la mesa
ahora vamos a usar nuestras pinzas
cocodrilo para sostener y colocar
nuestro arduino si tienen un compañero
él o ella les puede ayudar a sostener el
mano en su lugar solo asegúrense de que
sostengan el enano solamente por las
esquinas las partes que tienen pequeños
agujeros no queremos apretar alguno de
los componentes ya que si lo tomamos con
pinzas y apretamos los podemos romper y
nuestro circuito ya no va a funcionar
como debe ya que sostenemos el circuito
vamos a colocar nuestro conector de
pines hembra macho y nos aseguramos de
que los pines se toquen mutuamente
ahora coloco estas otras pinzas cangrejo
para sostener todo en su lugar
y tomamos nuestro cautín y soldadura y
vamos a soldar en la unión de estas dos
cosas
ponemos la soldadura suficiente para
asegurar una conexión sólida en cada una
de las uniones no queremos poner
demasiada soldadura ya que si unimos por
error dos pines con soldadura pues vamos
a tener problemas así que ponemos la
soldadura suficiente para tener una
buena conexión pero no tanta como para
que se esparza hacia otro pin
en el vídeo pueden ver que el humo de la
soldadura se aleja rápidamente porque
aquí tengo buena ventilación así que les
recomiendo que tengan a mano un
ventilador para ayudarles a alejar el
humo
y aquí pongo un poco más de soldadura y
ahora todos los pines están conectados
a quien me estoy asegurando de que estén
bien las conexiones del otro lado de la
misma forma que lo hicimos con el primer
lado
y ahora podemos quitar los excesos de
los pines que sobresalen de las uniones
usando las pinzas alicate y cuando lo
hagan asegúrense de usar lentes de
seguridad ya que estos pedazos pueden
salir volando directo a sus ojos tenemos
que asegurarnos de que las conexiones
que acabamos de hacer no toquen nada de
metal así que las vamos a cubrir muy
bien con cinta negra aislante como se ve
aquí y nos vamos a asegurar de que todas
las conexiones que hicimos queden bien
cubiertas de otra manera podrían tocar
alguna otra parte de metal causar un
cortocircuito y arruinar nuestra tableta
así que no queremos que ocurra esto
ahora estamos listos para conectar
nuestro arduino a nuestro robot